[Music]
oh good morning I hope you guys had a
great weekend football fans out there
you know a 50/50 but yeah hope you
enjoyed your weekend hope you enjoy you
know got all the great things done but
today we are playing dawn of fear which
is a PlayStation exclusive oh yeah new
game
did it come out today I think so this
morning I believe yeah thing it was
released to day and it's supposed to be
a mix of Resident Evil and Silent Hill
and you know that that whole creepy
spooky vibe survive type thing yeah and
I've seen um you know a little bit of
footage haven't played it yet there's
gonna be our first impressions of the
game yeah I'm either just saw the
trailer yeah exactly
let's go from what I saw I definitely do
get that vibe so yeah hope you guys are
ready because we are we're gonna get it
started do it we gotta come pretty music
here although not anymore as soon as I
press the button it was like that one
away really bad I was enjoying that
music as well but anywho thanks for
joining us guys getting a welcome happy
Monday let's go we got Jack and LJ and
first name lasting and
yeah oh okay itself who's this hi Alex
it's easy think also from Resident Evil
Jessica's dead oh no no bad news
oh and committed suicide very bad news
ouch well rough start
[Music]
that guitar might be of Silent Hill the
intro to that yeah
[Music]
you know just a little David Sunday it
is
well here we are yeah I was Sunday
already
[Music]
it only feels sad it's like the house
rejects me as if it hated me I suppose
everything finished as soon as possible
okay let's go whatever it's gotta be oh
so now we're jumping right into it
honestly this is like the fastest we've
ever gotten into game play with a new
game sorry I thought there'd be tank
controls but there aren't it's actually
just using the dual the analog stick and
it's going great but it's just it's
really responsive all right let's uh
test out the buttons here's my notebook
all right I don't have any weapons yet
or any abilities it seems except the
notebook let's look around actually that
guy was still sitting over there let's
test out the talk and feature chat okay
I will
why don't you take a walk around your
old house that means we should know
exactly where we're going everyday yep
ah if that was a closet I would have
been like yes it's the bathroom is
exactly they got the camera angles the
artwork and the seemingly pointless
rooms so far we're on the right track
okay anything to examine no big door
spooky angle I've seen that in Resident
Evil before for some [ __ ] busting to the
window a piano very ready stop saying
that ooh sparkly stuff paper paper here
yes right there yeah
hmm check me note well let's refer to
our notes turn pages
weapons I okay so that's where you check
your notes like someone was getting lost
in that house a chess piece is full
later I'm sure I'm sure
yeah something check me and then a chess
piece why not yeah this is how you seem
confirmed yeah great pop Jake says how
are your days going going well going
well yeah so far so good
yeah it's 11 a.m. here so so technically
morning time
oh yeah right and early for us um but
yeah we're just starting me I hope you
guys are also doing well how are your
days going this doors locked
this one is not right the beginning of
every game it's like which room can I go
in can I not go right is there a key in
the bathtub
another door past the bathroom oh this
is definitely an intricate house I
wonder how it looks outside yeah is
there is there a map I'm pressing the
all the buttons and no pool you can do
that if we can back up children's a
little bit just cause it's like empty on
the paper wallpaper yen get out of here
there's nothing in here messing around
definitely a calm start I wonder how
long you have to walk around and return
to her before she like activates the
next part yeah we're gonna hear like a
scream and then I'm gonna have to run
back to that first room bet you a
million bucks oh I have no weapons
[Music]
wait the music has not gone back here we
go must be aware Oh at the same point oh
wait okay it wasn't a scream but it was
a gunshot yeah yeah uh he was sitting
right here what the oh my God look where
he is now
yo that was very fast wait how did the
gunshot go from him just literally being
crucified on to the door yeah look
here's the weapon okay well we have
fissile now
no why would the killer shoot him and
drop the gun
let's just equip this because we saw
whoo should I go back and shoot that guy
or look around the other way what do you
do
well he was laying on a piece of paper
so I can only assume that that paper
might be important let's go back for it
some extent that was over here sorry guy
[ __ ] I was rough for him was it this toy
I already forgot no it was this one oh I
only have a gun with seven points
lucky number seven shot yeah let's see
okay good it is very much like Resident
Evil okay hopefully that guy's creatures
and some coins hey he had money I heard
some poll I heard some metal clanking
oh okay okay so we just shot that guy
who shot himself or like who killed
himself and then he turned into a zombie
yeah ii did something go in there and
infect him and then he oh wait
they've cornered me and hmm oh okay okay
i'm trying to piece together the zombie
element like if he got infected or if
like he just died like walking dead
style and he automatically turns you
know yep all things to consider okay I
picked up everything into this room I
believe let's go something is that
that's what I wanted to see a chat was
asking how much did this cost 19.99
is a PlayStation exclusive definitely
getting those vibes even this the layout
of this house reminds me of the it
reminds me of more of Resident Evil 1 I
should save I guess I got the gun and I
yeah and I didn't take any damage
hey wait to say there's one what did
that say
a 100 you can only save however many
candles are on the pedestal that creepy
Wow okay good to know glad I just didn't
ignore that is where I came from each I
have two chess pieces now that door is
locked
it's working if I didn't go this way yet
the name of this game is Don of fear
mm-hmm okay we're back here now I can
explore past man are holding that yes it
seems oh wait yes pieces yeah let's oh
okay you used it great
there's probably way more oh where do
you have wait do you have to actually
know how to play chess to do this puzzle
sure hope not I do not know I'm a scrub
yeah well let's look around for more
before I do anything that looks like an
empty chess board still for the most
part I only know Wizards chests just
kidding I don't even know that
hey Frankenstein hmm life well that's
what's going on here people are coming
back from the dead interesting books
we've got here do I have to unequip the
gun there's too unequipped the gun or
something yeah just put the gun on the
shelf and tell it to sly trying all the
buttons right now what about that thing
in the middle a statue or something no
no what about this one which looks
similar to that oh the chandelier is
moving is it oh it's kind of swinging
huh what the heck I watched too many
ghost videos at home okay this meanwhile
there's still a dead guy here I know was
there anything on the table
negative this way I have not gone yet
let's go I have never mind not upstairs
up or down pursue
or check it out backwards okay yeah good
Oh
Oh an extra angle wow this is a like
pendant yeah zoom in is this a safe room
some strong resident evil vibes although
look at my character
it's definitely totally not to like
retro games pretty cool yeah these are
crap oh we can go up yep there's another
option
oh there we go oh yeah these fixed
camera angles and the the house the
layout of the house all remind me very
much of Resident Evil ones missing
wow the decor SH has changed it has so
is the music
this kind of sounded like the intro
music at them yeah this music sounds
like a lot of games I feel like I'm
thinking of like five different games
just two days gone I played a lot of
that I'm still hearing a lot of Silent
Hill yeah let her fragment so a piece of
it I should react wit my gun that's a
big fragment yeah looking for any clues
I have a bottle in which I pee into what
a shitty job I'm not gonna look around
for a bottle that was locked right yeah
savage mantas says these games with
fixed camera angles are a work of art
atmospheric I agree ditto
these are all lock y'all please be
unlocked
why isn't this our old out I just want
to put the gun there we go
dang it just shoot the door yeah this is
my own house we've only run into one
zombie yeah it's pretty tame hey come on
camera there we go okay maybe I should
mess around with the chessboard what do
you think although the music okay music
changed again oh wait try going down
that hallway again here wait this was
long I don't remember where that first
door in the other room okay that's
animation you can't like cancel out of
that one was gonna say something too I'm
scared
No I don't want to go back I definitely
I'll do it for you chat because anything
I need more indeed okay okay it's a-okay
pretty fast just trying
oh you yo oh no knife I don't have a
knife like resident evil oh yeah she's a
tank can I reload I have some bullets
yes but do I have to do that manually
god I hope not
no okay well she's down she's down but
that wasn't a very convincing death
thanks
should I save there were more
checkpoints conserve these candles
Ritchie okay well that was a good idea
going into that door because something
that was wrong wait is there something
on that table down there hmm no this one
had nothing right another door that will
another blue mark do these darn blue
marks yeah they're stronger than
modern-day locks something is shining in
that next room oh but I can't I said
what we self to figure out how to push
that shelf yeah okay chessboard
let's see what's up at least maybe it
hasn't boarded up door right there yeah
I looked at it I really need to find a
crowbar or something good thinking we
push up here this guy hmm yeah that's
gonna happen a lot because I don't play
chess
I don't play chess is that even a legal
move oh man do you think I was on the
right track by trying to play chess
though
possibly but I feel like that would be
kind of a stretch for like a video game
not everyone knows that a play chess
myself included most people do know how
to play chess more people than I
realized I was like hanging out at a
tournament one time that was I don't
really know how to play chess and
everyone was like wow she's really nice
girl we go checkers was the jail
I know checkers okay trapped already
warmer far as I go man those blue marks
huh great on the door yeah bad sign
we're gonna figure out how to open those
maybe I'm not looking thoroughly enough
I gotta click everything like I did in
the Resident Evil days
xx there has to be a random room we did
not go into yet
yeah or something I haven't searched
this table I'm just going through
everything so far fear has not dawned on
me just yet but I can appreciate like
the retro nods so far yeah me too I
don't know why there'd be like bullets
in this room but I'm just looking around
just in case hello yeah dang it and
there's no map system either at least
let me double check Wow maybe have to
find it yeah that's very find the
blueprints of the house I don't know who
keeps a map of their house in their
house that's true okay there's a safe
point again nothing else back here in
this one all right maybe we should just
mash that chessboard until something
happens
John you chat says go to the chests
hsave alright I'll go back I can't
figure out what else to do at the moment
but chat help us out if you know
anything about chess even though this is
like pretty new so I wouldn't expect
have like bro tips but that's like the
only thing we can still interact with
right now yeah I mean like if they know
how to play chess like tell if I can
make yeah I want to move the king or
queen they make him move a little no
that's already okay I can't I don't want
to go backward I just forgot like which
directions move which I know like the
king can either move I think we have to
check me the Queen I can't remember does
the king move like horizontally and
vertically all right oh yes nice didn't
you yeah I did so good job yeah I know
how to play chess I am a chess master
now I just know the king and queen they
can move like across the board one of
them can like go diagonally and one can
go I don't even know it it's all crazy
this looks like a number of minute six
three to five just going with it and
then enter should be down here no we
cleared out all right I don't need to oh
another angle no no game no I got an
alternate angle and I can't get out of
it oh he is missing or something okay
done examining possibly
all right Natalie oh no oh exit no rats
how did I get back to that like a madman
behold push any button so something
happens you're right you are at one
really busy right how did I get this oh
I'm looking around the room and I picked
something up by mistake but I'm stuck on
this screen okay where's my shadow I
have to find myself it's very deep for a
Monday morning but I have to find my
shadow if I'm close to the safe then I
can like get back to that screen and try
again I can't even tell what I'm looking
at there you should I try to well I
tried exit last time and it brought me
back to the safe screen
[Music]
confer no way am I ever gonna figure
this out but just the room we walked in
filled yes I went over there wait I went
I think through that door wait you're
right I'm not even sure I'm in the same
room anymore
let me back out dang it because I
couldn't even see your character when we
were in that third yeah we try to open a
door and go to the next room
oh gosh you guys I'm gonna have to reset
yeah I think something's glitched out
here yeah you know what let me just load
them do you wanna do you wanna like it
sucks cuz like this uh
I can hear I'm like ready right my
character is moving around I shouldn't
be facing this like oh boy
five five five five five five five dang
it
alright yeah no choice friends I got a
load of games sorry guys
it'd be like that but hey at least for
those who are just tuning in you can see
a little bit more of the intro oh and we
know what to do I got to move that I
know maybe we should have saved okay the
two chess pieces I gotta get wait didn't
even have the gun we don't even have the
gun oh my goodness we should have saved
all right it's fine it's fine I know
what to do it's fine
actually where did I find that gun do
you nope okay no our homie dropped it
remember get out of here man that room
that the that event is triggered if I go
past the bathroom and into that hallway
over here the first aid thank you very
much yeah rest in peace first run indeed
Akash yeah that uh that was a bummer I
was like right when we were finally
getting somewhere I don't have the gun
yet paper
okay when I walked out of this room I
walked to this room and I moved right
over here and then that shot happened
[Music]
somewhere over here and in like record
speed are luminous got obliterated yeah
I turned my back for like two seconds
this game is on the PSN store yes for 20
bucks indeed
oh no we're reliving this all over
where's the gun oh my god okay now I can
go back shoot the zombie just kidding
fools anyway accident yeah I'm not a pro
there we go
even down to the gun holding stance yeah
looks like Chris Redfield crazy spot I
mean I hate to like constantly be like
getting those vibes you know it's a good
thing I'm having fun at least alright
let's go
waste this fool again save maybe
afterwards you know still just as good
the second time what that was very
satisfying
there we go there was nothing else in
here
how many chess pieces do I currently
have I need three I think and Kingdom in
the chat City just join breagan put this
stream as watchable after it's finished
it's right up my alley
yeah after it's done it should be
automatically yeah loaded so you can
catch it from the beginning if you want
to be live with us just stick around but
you can also scrub back on this timeline
that you're watching and it'll you know
you can pick wherever you want to start
watching yeah we're only about 20
minutes in right now and we had run into
a weird glitch and we had to
you just miss it okay after this I'm
gonna save after I open the secret door
yes I had to move this guy fire I know
okay where was the nearest candelabra
though there should be one close by
there is one in the dining room this is
the dining room I believe now there's a
zombie in there though
yeah so we'll just pop her melon you
don't have to me bill do you feel like
saving leave no she's pretty fast see ya
I don't want to fight you
yeah you want to for the chat I mean it
took us like way more bullets last time
it did she was too close what'd you say
like it drops she dropped money or
something where was the king that time
yeah you're right we didn't even put the
kinky in that thing that time
Oh Oh or was it already in there when we
saved it was in the room where the first
zombie was okay it was behind him there
was two peace there was like bullets and
the King piece I think all right moving
okay any more now I'm wondering okay
here's where it freaked out last time
oh shoot yeah okay I'm not gonna examine
we're in the room yeah I'm not gonna
look at that keypad which oh yeah yeah
okay got you this is like some Charlie
dude [ __ ] I think we can easily find the
code now
I did it let's see if it's in here
Jessica what's the haps what's the scoop
the chat was saying they wanted to read
some of these he did okay so how long
have I been in this dorm regrets visit
me every night the demon stalked me and
look for their piece of meat whoa boy
I am giving them everything they ask me
for and more and I don't get any results
I've been with this pain so long that
it's already part of me okay but just
you have the code to this chat is asking
if it's unlimited mo know there's
there's limited MO and I've you have to
manually reload when it's out or it does
it for you I take that back I couldn't
figure out a way to hold and reload so
for now I'm just gonna say it'll it
reloads on its own a ki think it'll work
on the blue door wrong button I would
hope so
let's examine Oh second floor okay so we
can go up the stairs yeah it actually
tells you what your room that's
convenient
yeah I'm never pressing that keypad
again yeah until we 100% have the code
look to avoid that probably a door
handle watch
um I don't have anything that would work
with that door I don't believe I wasn't
able to go through this door closet
maybe it's like for show nope I'm
pressing X one more time just because I
feel like in this game all doors have a
purpose but nope I guess not yet I'll
probably unlock it from the other side
later okay we'll have a key let's go
upstairs
come on camera if I see anything where
the character comes out when the rooms
switch because it's not always like
you'll be walking through the wall
yeah sometimes adjust your kick your
thumb stick nice plant okay we were here
explored here before I have the key
[Music]
okay we'll have a key so there we go
finally a child big yikes
uh-oh that guy doesn't look fully dead
[Music]
these guys oh there's a lot going on
Adam some water I need to breathe yeah
you go you play no no you got this my
deal is that it went from like really
nothing going on to everything going
zero to 100 right there
but I'm here for it need to be here this
guy is he sent me back oh my goodness we
don't have a health bar oh I don't but
I'm holding my shoulder wrong button
again let me know he's about to die okay
I have little bullets a knife so let me
try to use this before so I don't die on
us my screen is clear now I wanted to
explore he is going Pam maybe I jump
down I'll probably die later
yes I'm pressing every button oh I'm
pressing everything oh I had wet though
[Laughter]
I sweat it though you die English yeah I
was like is it a straight-up translation
I didn't know Hoss was you I thought it
was something else the verb for like you
have Richie's speaks Finnish
oh no we went so far back that's okay
okay so I need to get the key from that
creepy look at the door that door leads
to the toilet whoa okay there's
definitely some technical issues with
this game not gonna lie oh okay I'll get
the blinky that fell later aha well
thank you okay
you have died as the yeah Thank You
Harry I was like you know we've seen
that in general and a lot of games so I
just naturally assumed it was you died
yeah but you know in Spanish class like
eons ago yeah I am wrong but I am NOT
there you go okay so I gotta get the key
I'm gonna tread like the Juke method and
just yeah I don't have many bullets
which is fine that's how you play these
games this second floor is live yeah
this was not this was not locked
let me see
if you like your work as it was walk
from the other side and it looks like
it's in a position when you can get to
it from the other way so you might not
have to go through that through them
again won't hurt to look
this key works for anything else no okay
it's double checking I'll be yeah from
the other side if I'm in a pinch maybe
I'll keep that in mind
okay here we go yeah try to run Paxton's
back okay
[Music]
okay there's only one running speed by
the way and I was the night
forget the knife let me get that knife
to see ya loser
alright got a knife now I might pick
them off from here because they're gonna
just go ha ha stumped
can i oh
reload reload is r1 okay nice excellent
so I need a turn right that's fine
oh I knew it
[Music]
I have always been bad at these controls
x2 jump jump jump down yeah yeah nice
let's try the knife I haven't used the
knife yet Equipe damn all right push
them off and then Oh
[Music]
help I'm trying to use right now oh no
you can't get the menu when I've got an
idea what's me except I don't know how
much they move when you're off screen
but try to like have to kill some floor
them more towards the door then Juke
them and run over the bridge so when you
come down you're at least not stuck in
that they wouldn't work wave any further
I don't like I don't think they'll move
any further when you're not on the
screen from what we've seen with like
the cutscenes are like of the doors
opening yeah whoa okay maybe if you try
to take one of them out remember you get
lucky with a headshot every now and then
yeah
[Music]
oh [ __ ] come on load okay not really
together men got the key check imagine
if you're just walking around IRL and
like your surroundings are glitching out
all right said wish there was an
indicator to show how much health you
have I agree it's kind of hard to tell I
we did notice it though earlier when we
applied the first aid that the screen
brightened up a little bit but when
you're in game you can really tell
and you hold if you're in pain or yeah
like a hole themselves yeah
[Music]
yeah you might have to just or just kill
yeah I'm gonna maybe shoot some and then
turn around too scared let's see what
happens how we reload we can maybe yeah
they're probably right there the first
guy we killed would've chased us I think
they're gonna be right there I'm screwed
I'm pressing everything you guys know
how it goes excuse me while I reload oh
okay well they're on the floor at least
stunned right now I want to get rid of
him
I want them creeping by the door it's
over for you Baldy and maybe I can
explore a little bit nothing is here
okay goodness we did it and I can
definitely Duke that weird other guy
yeah sure I can breathe a little bit
now for that whoops
and wonder how long this game is for a
key
so long yo the one five - cat says how
does the game work auto lock or manual
pretty it's it's like it is manual as
far as I can tell because you have to
like it's like this and it doesn't lock
on I wasn't you know those three zombies
were right in front of me and it
wouldn't Auto log on to anything and I
had to kind of poorly manually like
that's because I'm bad not because the
game design
that's just like Resident Evil 101 okay
so I got a new key let's see let me
examine it and see what's what it's for
that's the one I got earlier yes oh my
goodness that'll open up at least two
doors that I know of none of these right
no blue doors we read that already we
should save yeah
there's no safe upstairs though but I'll
go down there and save
[Music]
making progress
where was the key was the chessboard
oh yeah the double doors okay cool
burritos dad yes hey welcome back yes
for only oh where is she though I can't
I'm not gonna go to the right okay
there's another safe spot like you near
the blue doors I need to go to anyway so
I'll use those over here one of them was
locked one of them to the way out see
here five one one five two cat said I'd
love this on switch this definitely
looks like a switch can like it would
some of them are making their way by one
I am getting that new animal crossing
switch I don't care oh the whole console
yes yeah I I'm just waiting for one that
I visually liked a lot and that one's it
I'm excited here we go okay I've used
both these saves I'm not going through
that room anymore here's a blue door
around the corner such an interesting
concept I wonder why they made it like
that mmm-hmm
cuz I'm an obsessive saver Oh
oh it was a regular slow-moving one I
don't appreciate the music right now
yeah let me get that help present I'm
mashing X oh you're right
whoops I'm just trying to there we go
I'll switch this one now I just want to
move to the next knob but it's not okay
here we go I'm just taking a wild guess
cuz that we need to apparently get that
Oh gauge in the middle there there we go
confirm selection well I thought I did
that's fine
I want to look around this room anyway
cut metal I think the power alright
these creatures actually referred to a
zombies or what's the story on them to
be honest we haven't gotten much story
yeah just in the way of these letters
and like they're there but being vague
Bob Jones elyda yes I am totally getting
that switch you know it's tax return
season treat myself a little bit because
I'm obsessed it's so pretty it so cute
okay it's not letting me control it
anymore so I think I did what I wrote I
fixed it but it's probably affecting an
area I haven't been to yet outside of
this door let me double check burn me
out so that wasn't music it was just
that room oh he's creeping up on this
back there it's locked from the other
side of Cure's
hey goddamn they come back though that's
something we've learned that lady in the
dining room I think when we died again
and came back we just sped right but I
turned the power on what are you doing
serve man this isn't a museum well we
have a another blue door to open up so
let's find it
it was somewhere over here look at that
i unlock the door oh oh it's here sick
burritos dad preciate you me and I'm
trying it's it's blocked not locked
well downstairs was hair blue door no
wait there was something here we were
yeah
damn well let's look around some more
that's one thing about games like this
or you have to do a lot of like room
searching that's part of it all looks
the same and like that's the nature of
the beast
that was blocked I've just unlocked that
one wait over here
there's the dining room but this store I
forgot maybe is that another hallways it
locked this was the first song when and
yeah this one did have a blue door
anything something shiny down there out
this window I'm waiting for dogs to bust
Oh two bullets and a knife let's the
other nice okay all right now um now we
can get all the stuff that we either
drop it works all outside yeah
more ammo convenience okay let me take a
breath in here I'm not gonna waste my
bullets reload my piece and see that's
so loud and let's see where that key
goes you hear breathing that is me
Bronski oh the whole fist isn't included
there was that door our thing earlier
that was like it looks like something's
missing remember that remember that door
that said that oh yeah let's see if I
think I could take the key by cutting
the metal oh the bandsaw duh I just
passed that area that power room oh that
was shoot I forgot already
okay
through here I came from through here
remember after I unlocked let's let's
backtrack in this area I have no sense
of direction so even more hilarious
trying to be like yeah totally that
that's where it was Richie I'm pretty
bad myself but even when I use Google
Maps I guess for some reason still
something thank goodness okay now I can
remove the hand from the key I think oh
I got it let's see if I could
did it really eat my tea no way or is
that the new key
we have to do something wrong it ain't
my thing
wait go back okay I used it on this see
because it can cut thick metal so I used
it and it didn't give me anything back
unless double check everything here I
don't know why it would appear over here
but I'm freaking out because the key
that I oh no no
son of us what now I'm really unsure
what to do oh man
it ate Mikey did it this is like a bad
mini machine right I'm gonna kick this
damn thing can you see it on the counter
no I think we know and the chat says
it's a bug should I
alright so so far we've seen like two
game-breaking bugs yeah that caused us
to reset oh man well at least it's a
known bug I don't feel like an idiot and
Chad is here to make me feel better but
now I really don't know what to do
because when was the last things that we
saved not that long ago I think after I
[Music]
that still out of order right like I'm
screwed
yeah it's not like we started before we
go thank you friend
alright let's see let's just I'm like I
don't know I kind of want to like just
try that when I doing wrong menu here
dang it yeah but is there a way around
the book so far as anything but it's
probably good yeah like a hundred
percent of the time where are we gonna
get lucky like they did last time and
they might not yeah I guess there's only
one I'm not gonna lie that's probably
one of my biggest pet peeves of games
something game breaking and then I have
to go back and I lose progress and like
that is it's very big do I even have the
key okay yes that's good and then
remembering where you were with that
last seems like yeah no point like I
can't name my save files okay so i did
adjust the power yet I don't think oh no
[Music]
this is donna fear it's brand-new came
out today there are some game breaking
bugs so far but people in chat has said
that the developers know so possibly a
patch is on the way or something to fix
it oh man somebody said even weird
things down to like confirmation sound
effects now so that sounds good but like
the problem is I did it right but the
game okay
tamati you said is it scary no and
that's coming from me there's a zombie
rabbi excuse me
alright one fights you cats and sadly I
have to go but thanks for showing me
this title I'll look at look for it
myself soon thank you so much for tuning
in hope you enjoyed and have a good day
happy Monday
happy Monday good have you around let's
see here
where was the other blue door for God
already okay he remembered something
yeah well let me examine that key before
I chop it up or before it eats it you
sit down the hallway no no oh man we got
bamboozled is this game the sequel to
layers of fear no definitely not I open
this window I want the thing with the
shiny chips always but it's scary
because you never know when you'll have
to restart yeah you're right that is
kinda scary yeah
this is full speed by the way okay
bullets that door is locked
oh [ __ ] okay I confuse myself with one
of the zombies I just want to make sure
I'm not missing anything my hands up
like that yeah there door here little
dark ass corner just check-in everything
let me confirm that this is log thanks
oh gosh what did I miss I went mute for
a bay you missed us running into another
game breaking bugging we had to start
over again
yeah cos you might not be able to get
much further than this oh I wanted to
examine the new key let me reload my
penis first me too and their heavy
breathing so we got this key which is
stuck to this hand from the statue right
they clearly save let's save right now
okay
telling me by cutting the metal I can
extract the key right we found a saw
that can cut through thick metal but as
soon as I do that it ate my key and it
didn't give it back so where can I save
the big dining-hall this might be the
last big save cuz we're in a pickle here
folks where is this person
[Music]
you can well okay yes using our same
might as well go for you we have a lot
of saves yes Jacob
she says fingers crossed that this bag
won't prevent us from continuing it
definitely has to be addressed that's
it's a day one problem I see a little
gap here I want to push this door come
in stupid zombie with the the way I was
trying to go
did y'all play Petey yes that that game
is terrifying
that game is if you thought I lost my
[ __ ] down slender the arrival Lord PTA
it was like ten times worse
Petey actually was what made me think I
didn't like scary games cuz I was too
chicken but then I actually found out
like last year I really love scary games
and so then yeah I made me like back on
that whole experience and then like yeah
if you haven't played it and like I
don't really think you can play it now
unless someone has some new mod or
whatever we're like PC or something that
I think you can mod it to get it back
but if you haven't played in or if you
can't mod it just go watch it's like
people playing it on YouTube it's
hilarious
okay that goes back to the main hall
good but I need to get back to that
bandsaw room we gotta try it again
there's no other that's the only way to
progress although I needed a guide to
meet PC because it was actually very
complicated thank you I will play it
until I got absolutely stuck and go read
the guy and get past the part and then
play it so I got stuck again oh my
goodness all right moment of truth
you guys okay so just to Rick just to
rephrase what's going on there's a key
that I need that's in this fist and I
can cut the fist off with this saw
coming out but when I do so last time I
did this it took away the hand and the
key so here's the saw right here right
you can cut through thick metal the
powers on ready to go so I go to my
items and by pressing X I use it that it
just goes away
nothing like we're at a dead end here I
can keep exploring I feel like okay you
know let's try to like put the key
without reading examining interest can
you do that like this walk up to it and
use the key I don't remember
let's try yeah nothing to lose I did
turn the power on oh wait did you turn
it back on this run
yeah okay I did it wouldn't I could tell
cuz they wouldn't let me mess with the
board anymore
oh yeah even in the the line it says the
power yes inventory run I can run by
pressing a square I thought I was
already going from speed oh well let's
try it I mean not that it'll get away
from me you crazy lady okay come over
here first so I can do Q this psycho
speed I tried it just alright so you
said just using this I can walk up to it
and use it but don't click like examine
thus offers like maybe that screen is
good I don't know I'm just trying to
like let's try different ways whatever
whatever we can muster up here I guess
like last-ditch effort after that just
like close out the whole application
restarted not a bad I mean who knows
I haven't unlocked this yet okay but I
know how to maybe if I don't turn the
power on and examined it would be like a
specific order like in a glitchy way
like a specific order of doing things
wrong what I don't know I'm just
thinking in game-breaking mode okay let
me unlock this wall I'm here
and go back nope
last time I did it all in one motion
that's okay all right Chad if you have
any tips I mean we're just trying
everything here gosh this guy still gets
it every time
OOP yeah that's probably the only scary
thing about this game so far like just a
enemy being right there when you walk
through the door and you're just not
expecting it and you're like oh that
door by the way that I saw for a split
second it was locked so I can't even
just looking around present excellent
everything see okay right now the power
is on so I can't test my theory but okay
so without yeah nope
all right I'll try it I'm not even gonna
look at it I'm just gonna use it yeah
really we're doomed I can't access that
key all right I say restart the
application oh right okay try it again
if it doesn't work that's a wrap folks
at least I can look around some more but
geez you know might be doomed here so
it's off let's fire it back up maybe I
don't know
I'm glad chat mentioned earlier that
this is a known bug we are rebooting the
game how are we doing anyway chat this
game yeah I think this game is broken
sight sorry those developers are
publishers I think games like this are
definitely made for a specific group of
people myself included I was pumped it's
got some old survival horror vibes and I
was having a pretty good time but we
we're stuck that's all we're stuck this
game is currently $20 on PlayStation
Network where are you at where you at
okay
she's just wasted from the party mover
that sounds like a 20/20 like cheesy
parody horror movie everyone goes
through this air B&B big mansion and
then it's actually filled with zombies
okay just clicking around for anything
any alternate way around this and Yuki
any piece of paper we saw that already
alright let's just go for it then enough
dawdling you do some research here there
you go we have technology punch the ps4
like Patrick nothing else here no key in
the bathtub that would have been too
on-the-nose on guys
okay I went the wrong way alright so
we've reset the game just to a little
puppy it's just ice this guy but I don't
need to
I wonder what that key opens
and then one scared even like you've it
again I have one more idea we can try if
this doesn't work which it might not
work I might just like it okay so using
the saw to get the key out of this hand
[Applause]
the chat's ideas okay great
where does Keith Rico let's see the
green house that was outside oh man I
can't save anymore but it's okay maybe
there's another candelabra coming out
soon
all right man
way to kill my vibe you dumb zombie I'm
just gonna Adelina on the chat said to
people literally made this really
because if that's true
and this is really good for two people
yeah we're just two people playing it
I know load it up
where's I don't know get outside do the
hallway the hallway turn around oh go
back to home way on the wall take your
left there's the dining room oh right
the first door hallway okay yeah Chad
saves the day Chad always saves the day
and there were two zombies out here I'm
just gonna try to get past them again
oh they're hanging out with each other
okay good
if it was like you don't have the right
gear what save I should I should have
seen okay fine I will I was deciding
what to do guys that was unsure all
right wasting yeah I could actually see
him like off axis a little great love
that sound
there should be bullets soon let me just
save just you just save cuz I can yeah
hello boy yes I press X there we go
got him that's to be an achievement you
filled out all the save slots okay is
that a door behind him buzzers something
on the ground collect yes just in time
so glad there's just pistol ammo
everywhere that was always my favorite
part about all these like styles of
games so random yeah
bullets in is all over this mansion
later Baldy hate you oh good he's
bleeding that means he's dead dead save
point was this a window decorative door
I can't go through it is wait I wasn't
ready I'm not scared
I want to go back I'm not done exploring
in there yeah I think let me just at
least look around there might be more
bullets I know it's been a while since
we see one of these note on the corpses
there's so many what have we done that
woman wants to kill every one of us all
that she pretends is unreadable
everything and we've helped her
unreadable name it address withheld
alright
so bad news more bad news
yeah well there's really bad things
going on here what's up a mod we are
having a great day we hope you're having
a good day too happy Monday happy Monday
and I haven't done this in a while but
on Mondays I usually like to try and set
a goal for myself for the week and I
usually try to ask you guys to set a
goal for yourself too so myself yeah I'm
gonna say my motivation this week my
goal this week is to finish this dang
kingdom hurts
three DLC a I have not finished it yet
lacking I but are you having fun like do
it do it if you want I don't want you to
slug through a game you don't want to
play I'm like I feel like I'm about
halfway through and I haven't even
gotten to play Kyrie it which was a
reason why I even bought the DLC so yeah
that you're gonna get back into it so I
can actually use her but yeah that's my
goal for the week you guys it didn't
have to be anything big a crazy just
gotta be something that you think you
can feasibly do so that by the end of
the week you feel accomplished for
yourself so shout it out Chad what do
you guys up to this week what do you
want to go and what's your goal Richie
um I kind of stopped going on these
morning walks and I kind of want to get
back into it
I just keep sleeping in it's cold out
there
good and it's warm inside so a stream of
air passes through the bricks I think I
could blow up this wall with an
explosive wowzers wowzers okay so I'm
glad I went back and explored but it's
time to go back outside
Blackjacks says I'm stuck where can I
get the safe code when you find out you
let us know because we don't know the
safe code either oh yeah we haven't come
back to that we also got stuck on the
safe code screen yeah so we've been a
little scared to go back to it okay I've
got bullets I'm ready I mean before I go
through any doors let me look okay I
hear something
maybe just the wing tips oh is that my
goal is to survive work until the end of
the weekend relatable crap so here's the
greenhouse there's two at least two at
least they're not that Oh that day as
you literally get yoked oh there was
something blocking me those herbs here
well there's first aid kit you guys
heard that I got equip that I gotta cook
the knife
wait you picked up a journey from oh it
was a little piece you were you were I
think you were looking something up Bart
talking to child I picked up this little
piece with an X on it and I think it
goes back into that first room where
there's that door and it says it looks
like something's missing so I might
check that out if I look like a grenade
like that's what I know equip that night
here we go see my last my last-ditch
efforts no end
yo-yo is the is the knife the the MVP
like is the best weapon it's it's the
tech the knife is Opie and it saved my
life I hear another one I'm scared
because these fix camera angles you know
they do you dirty I knew you okay and
he's blocking a door to you Janet even
2003 Akash really set it off with that
one did you just say that right yeah
okay so I'm a little surrounded but the
knife that's your help the eyes thank
you am i low enough
yeah there is I wanted to strut out of
there wow that was a cool scene yeah
yeah we should go back to the middle and
just slow walk okay for you chat yeah
someone please edit an explosion behind
it perfect angle it's stuck I'm just
kidding ah this is for ps4 yes oh okay
so what did I I made some progress I
collected a solving this all paint pink
okay I don't remember in instance yeah
hmm okay well we'll keep that in mind
can't interact with the mechanism yeah
you he'll you'll see you know my cell I
have plenty of help
ah oh good okay now I'm gonna go back to
where I think my mechanical piece will
work green house check should I save
there's that candelabra right here I
made some pretty [ __ ] I mean some pretty
good progress might as well see plus we
have 20 minutes
are you sure oh he said them because we
said we kept saying get the shiny are
you sure yeah okay I kind of went over
here for a second it was just I already
picked okay this is where I found the
piece okay but there's a little hallway
over here that's they almost try to hide
from you well I went down there okay
yeah yeah they try to hide that you
[Music]
can't trick us yeah kandel as a spells a
little oh they're alive again no thanks
good thing there nice and slow he's not
freaking out doesn't have no board I
just hope that if a zombie apocalypse
ever truly happens that the zombies are
slow okay yeah girl cannot run I got
some bad ankles this guy's still dead
yeah
oh this thing something's missing right
I got the perfect thing I hope it does
it no we're good
we used the piece oh thank goodness
what something else is missing then oh
yeah wait back away from the door it
looks like you need another one on the
other side and on the mug oh well right
not a glitch
there's gotta be one in the safe a safe
but oh we don't even have a number yet
I'm not happy with that safe this is
still not a door and it kills me this is
not a door that you can use open why
won't you open okay well what's the next
move here I have did I use that key oh I
use the key for the the garden the one
that was remembered in the hand I use
that I've looked around pretty
thoroughly does that key work for
anything else I still have it no just
for the green house we have to be able
to use the solvent on something painted
what was pain okay because I noticed
that some of the walling upstairs was
kind of falling apart you got we have a
lead trying to think what's paint
related up here yeah have I opened every
door okay
no with ruh there
please double-check this hallway
so this is the song that reminds me of
Silent Hill okay nothing obvious needs
painting over in this holler they let me
back up here
going here
we know this opens up now okay there
were Hellas on bees in here earlier
remember bad times in this room
now you bodied them rich he did and they
never came back they were pulverized I
know you know the room were above now
like that is the book the book shop that
we pushed over
don't have bossman around oh yeah
there's still that shiny piece down
there how can you get over in the air I
still figured that out even let's go
back to the garden house maybe there's a
way around that I just missed that looks
pretty open down there those double
doors I'm looking down there let's let's
at least go there you might have a lead
song name please I have no idea some of
these tracks are definitely like chill
chill vibes it makes me feel so angsty
and I were vibing
geez yeah what needs picture uh-huh
there's a lot of artwork so it's kind of
vague Oh was the garden house downstairs
no no just I'm thinking I think through
here I'm not sure if I mean we probably
can kill that crawling pincer thing but
oh you think you would give us something
for that challenge geez
oh this is not the garden house this is
a oh it is a shortcut to the garden
house now because I unlock that door
excuse me oh yeah what about the
elevator we still it still says
something about getting the power on
yeah it's a restaurant or something out
of my way okay well you know what I'm
really glad we got past that bandsaw
glitch does that could do this I was
getting annoyed not gonna lie okay I'm
probably missing a you know all these uh
these angles like I'm probably missing
something Ronny in the chances sure
seems good so far I hope this spawns
more indie games like of this I agree
I love indie games actually because you
know if I had the capability to make a
game that actually functioned and looked
halfway decent yeah I'd be pretty stoked
to be pretty proud too
it's not easy making games coding is a
whole world of its own okay yeah I can't
even begin to think so yeah we're with
you Ronnie I'm just double-checking here
there's also no flashlight in this game
which
but yeah that there was a dead body with
something shining which I don't think we
can get to yeah we haven't seen those
double doors yes but we're downstairs
we're in the right area let me go back
in here anything over here and he hidden
camera angle nope first do you want to
try no enjoy I only know I'm just very
very bad at these style of controls for
games so for your own sake that's for
you yeah yeah Ritchie he's a pro we meet
when we were playing Resident Evil the
other day he was killing it I love
Resident Evil yeah because there has to
be something that's that well can we go
look in the world I tried I picked
something up like bullets from there but
there's no other inner like interacting
with it should i spray paint this wall
or at least try to do something with the
paint no it is something exploit yeah
definitely not gonna accidentally waste
my paint
check in the corners here stuck for a
second this is a big-ass scary basement
I mean with a little bit of renovations
and you know DIY home decor I've been on
my home decor cake a lot of potential in
this house exactly open floor plan
[Music]
[Laughter]
people want that this looks like a man
cave waiting to happen I don't think the
well those scary what the heck okay
no no exit from here just scary but
there's a way to blow up that wall
somehow we need something paint first
spray paint is ladies night these good
know what I'm scared if I die I'd be I
wouldn't forgive myself
he just shuffled over okay see you like
here is all right they're right outside
the door is the shining babe okay y'all
quit breathing on me please that's where
that dead guy is I'm telling you this
thing is a door but he won't move yeah
it looks like it's those are the durian
he became oh my god you're right ha
these are the double doors
you just had to die right there can I
like spray paint over him what can you
tell know you've already interacted with
him like 10 times I'm sorry take one of
those things out looks like what we need
for that other two mistakes oh my gosh
we do need one more item or at least one
you're thinking too should I play more
chess
no I think that I'm not gonna mess with
that there's something we're missing
yeah paint what needs painting one needs
a touch-up of things or anything in that
cabinet no isn't letting me I'm pressing
the mashing eggs it was like I think we
cleared this area but I just feel like
I'm playing Resident Evil was that
locked from the other side gadzooks
we're lost this - okay mental note both
of these are locked they're wooden doors
break them down that's the that's the
argument I had like through my whole
childhood playing video games
great like you're a cop with a gun Leon
you can figure this out when we're back
here
[Music]
this is puzzling chatty I need tips slav
from the other side I don't know there's
gonna be any tips on Google this is just
came out today boy you think I should
kill that spider guy or at least try to
explore that room let's go back
I've run around a lot but I didn't
really making that much progress so if I
die he just showed up right away maybe I
can spray spray paint he's calm right
now
he knew that or he died and it's not
registering because the music's back to
normal Lisa can explain so he had some
prisoners it wasn't as strong as I
thought he was but that was the game and
he didn't drop anything
well he didn't properly die either but I
think we were okay ador Wow a whole area
we didn't see before
oh it's probably unlocked from that
hallway earlier no you know what the
knife works so much better than the gun
anyway but I'll reload maybe I can paint
this wall no I'm just hearing we haven't
been through he's over there I'm sure
like right where I'm facing you that are
now face your peers ready go
I feel more comfortable with tonight I'm
not gonna lie I'm going for it oh no
creepy ass hallway change your mind Rock
Lake oh all those brains on this nice
hardwood floor I know but there's also
this interesting artwork all right where
is this person I want them to come to me
yeah oh here they come
use me ma'am do you know where I can use
this solvent no oh my god there's no
like change weapons there isn't at least
as far as I could tell oh my god another
one another one another one you need
help let you down for me I think they
did that's a really small closet Oh
piece number two yo the elevator that
don't work oh my god whenever we get
that working it's gonna be very cool
this looks like an you be painted yeah
she's screaming I'm also scared though
so I'm gonna I'm gonna do my food I walk
oh this is a small person well I say she
cause just her voice sounds like a
woolly buy don't know anymore
oh okay get Juke y'all oh it's gonna say
if it's locked
oh it's back here well I want to go back
and explore so actually the knife is is
the
ready chips away with the we make a
progress out here right hey finally
slice and dice fruit ninja fruit ninja
fruit she says you I hate you oh right a
little ones so tough Chips Ahoy did you
just assume that Dom B's gender I
incorrectly did I actually still don't
know I mean there is only four minutes
left of our stream today I'm gonna run
ya towards that area again then I think
I know because I feel like we did a lot
in between the last thing or actually we
did a lot of searching soul search to
find what we actually needed dang this
game is called dawn of fear
yes whatever you got I screwed up that
little zombie man maybe since she was
short the knife was just going over her
head
that be a program English for her dodge
I can't there's no like a Jill Valentine
dodge and this that I could figure out
that he's sick yeah okay so we have to
go to spider boy spider oh yeah and that
was over here upstairs I believe no wait
that was through the bookshelf it was oh
yeah right in to the bookshelf glad
you're here
[Laughter]
hey wait I thought this room only had
the oh oh whoops yeah this we have the
piece one piece we don't have that safe
combo never doing that again
John wick he says I always come here
near the end of these streams damn it
John wick oh man
11 a.m. Pacific time that's when we are
live every weekday hope you can make it
sooner next time but hey this will be a
vods you're catching it at the good part
we just finally found out we're supposed
to go so man that's gotta go around back
in this area good good gonna run as best
I can like the board respond yeah I'm
gonna ignore your ass we don't got time
to deal with you know
wait the key the key wait the item the
key Oh more important shiny things
whoa call it when you're ready purrs I
know we want to have time to keep going
for very much longer but I've got to see
what's over here we finally got over
here
I didn't go this way oh I did I hate
that little one third one a fourth one I
might be doing my notebooks all bloody
yeah we made it now I think also they
hate me
well it just led me back here but we
have that piece for the door we can
write maybe address next time or at
least you want to just run downstairs
and do it real quick okay you know it's
fine it's fine
you know what just run down there and do
it while we do our outro all right you
guys thank you so so much for tuning in
and checking out dawn of fear with us
yeah obviously a huge nod to throwback
Artie style games we had a good time
there were definitely some glitches and
some bugs yeah but hey from what I heard
so far
if those details are true about the
developers it doesn't seem like they had
a big team and it looks great for you
know just a few people's work I got a
apparently I'm not sure how true that is
but if it is and that's pretty good
that's great yeah we saw it a great time
for like the first 90 minutes of the
game definitely vibing with some
Resident Evil feels you know and if you
enjoyed it you can snatch it up on ps4
right now it's 20 bucks and yeah hope
you enjoyed the stream happy Monday you
guys hope you are able to remove all of
your weekly goals
week and have a good one tune in
tomorrow we're playing some eep eggs
lady oh yeah we'll see you then yo peace
out y'all
[Music]
you
[Music]
you